oui
avec ses ruelles sinueuses ces quartiers
pittoresques lisbonne réussit presque à
faire oublier une page sombre de
l'histoire récente du portugal
[Musique]
joão farina peut témoigner des ravages
de la drogue dans son pays pendant 30
ans il a consommé alors que l'épidémie
était à son plus fort autour de lui des
amis ont perdu la vie
[Musique]
dans les années 90 au portugal la
consommation de drogues prenait des
proportions alarmantes
cent mille personnes étaient accros à
l'héroïne c'est un pour cent de la
population
aucune classe sociale n'était épargné à
cette époque c'était pratiquement
possible de trouver une famille qui
n'avait pas des problèmes avec les bras
face à cette crise le portugal a pris
les grands moyens en 2001 le
gouvernement à décriminaliser l'usagé la
possession de toutes les drogues les
trafiquants sont toujours considérés
comme des criminels mais pas les
consommateurs les toxicomanes sont
dorénavant traités comme des malades
le docteur lula ou ancien médecin de
famille est l'architecte de cette
réforme majeure le portugal arabe
ordonné la répression et le rêve
inaccessible d'une société sans drogue
complètement nous savons que ça
n'arrivera pas mais en pratique comment
ça fonctionne
cette jeune femme a été interpellée par
les policiers en fin de semaine même si
elle avait du haschich sur elle et ne
fera face à aucune accusation
ce matin ce n'est pas un tribunal qui
l'attend ni un juge est là plutôt au
rendez vous avec des professionnels de
la santé au portugal toute personne
prise avec une quantité de drogue qui
équivaut à moins de 10 jours de
consommation est convoqué devant une
commission de diffusion médecin
travailleur social et psychologue évalue
sa consommation est décédé des mesures à
prendre
le comité peut simplement fermé le
dossier imposer des travaux
communautaires ou une amende
les sanctions ne sont pas plus grave que
pour une contravention de stationnement
ou encore conduire sans sa ceinture
le comité s est d'abord de renseigner et
de recommander des traitements si
nécessaire oui dont le but n'est pas de
faire la main
al s'ils font le choix de continuer à
consommer au moins ils seront mieux
informés une approche ouverte des
conseils utiles même si elle ne
considère pas avoir des problèmes de
consommation mais pour d'autres aucun
doute le système portugais a tout changé
[Musique]
bruno avait perdu le contrôle de sa vie
sa dépendance lui a coûté son emploi il
ne pouvait plus prendre soin de sa fille
cette équipe d'intervenants sur le
terreau et lui a permis de se reprendre
en main et c'est bon ça m'a sauvé dit il
ces unités mobiles financé par le
ministère de la santé arpentent les rues
de lisbonne distribuer des doses
quotidiennes de méthadone un substitut à
l'héroïne
[Musique]
les nokia les utilisateurs ont accès à
un médecin sur place
en revêtant le dr gomes a vu les
changements
autrefois les appels pour surdose
étaient quotidiens plus maintenant
l'état de santé des patients
s'améliorent même le rapport
la relation entre allait les techniciens
et l'air voilà le niveau de confiance à
évoluer positivement
[Musique]
c'est justement pour bâtir des ponts que
joie au travail auprès des toxicomanes
lui et son équipe connaissent bien cette
ancienne gare c'est un repère pour les
consommateurs d'héroïne
cet homme n'est pas le seul à s'injecter
plusieurs doses par jour pour réduire
les infections l'équipe distribuer des
seringues neuves et récupère celles qui
ont été utilisées mais il faut plus il
n'y a toujours pas de ses déjections
superviser au portugal et les
intervenants sur le terrain n'ont pas
accès à la naloxone pour traiter les
surdoses il y a deux ou trois mois une
personne est morte ici et nous étions
impuissants explique john
[Musique]
certes le modèle portugais n'est pas
parfait mais bien peu de gens
reviendrait en arrière
les chiffres sont éloquents pour environ
360 surdoses mortelles par année au
milieu des années 90 au portugal il n'y
en avait plus que 40 en 2015
chez les toxicomanes le nombre annuel de
diagnostic de vih sida est passé de près
de 1800 à seulement 44 au cours de la
même période la criminalité elle aussi à
diminuer et les personnes dépendantes
sont plus nombreux à recevoir de l'aide
le docteur lula ou insiste c'est le
résultat de tout un système pas
seulement de la décriminalisation il
faut travailler beaucoup et offrir des
réponses diverses travail et à la
prévention si bien sûr tout offrir le
traitement tous ceux qui en ont besoin
les défenseurs du modèle portugais sont
convaincus qu'ils offrent beaucoup plus
[Musique]
md nous redonnons aux gens humanité et
dignité
zhao a retrouvé la sienne et veut
redonner à son tour ses missions est un
peu à l'image de la proche portugaise
aider sans juger sans condamner
[Musique]
alors oui on vous retrouve ici on voit
bien que ça fonctionne pour le portugal
mais est-ce que c'est réaliste de penser
qu'un modèle comme celui là pourrait
être exporté chez nous d'autres pays ont
choisi de suivre l'exemple du portugal
on n'a qu'à penser à la norvège par
exemple les choisit de décriminaliser à
la fin de l'année 2010 est est ce que
c'est possible au canada on a posé la
question
celui qui a été l'architecte du modèle
portugais le docteur goût là où il pense
que le canada n'a rien à perdre vu
l'ampleur de la crise à laquelle il fait
face
il s'est lui même rendu à vancouver pour
constater les ravages causés par le
fentanyl il pense que le canada pourrait
bénéficier d'une approche qui est mieux
coordonner mieux structuré mieux
structuré il pense aussi que peu importe
le pays
le fait de criminaliser comme ça les
toxicomanes ne fait que les pousser
davantage en marche du système de santé
ne fait que les stigmatiser davantage
mais on en est où ici qu'est ce qu'en
pensent nos politiciens je perdais
plusieurs élus du parti libéral du
canada et qui sont peu résistant je vous
dirai pas ce qu'il faut dire que
politiquement c'est très très très
délicat comme proposition déjà les
libéraux en ont plein les bras avec la
légalisation du cannabis mais en plus
avec le modèle la décriminalisation il
faudrait vraiment l'expliqué très bien
aux canadiens faire la distinction en
décriminaliser est légalisée je voudrais
qu'en fait semaine il va y avoir un
débat sur cette question au congrès du
parti libéral
l'entente d'un député qui va voter en
faveur de cette résolution d'aller voir
qu'un ministre de la santé elle a choisi
de fermer la porte rapidement avant même
que le débat n'ait lieu on les écoute
je crois que le fait de décriminaliser
et de regarder la toxicomanie comme un
problème de santé plus grand problème de
justice pourrait commencer à nous donner
des pistes de solution beaucoup plus à
long terme
j'ai bien rentrer en train de tout les
points de vue c'est que je veux dire et
puis mais encore une fois je dois dire
que notre premier ministre a été très
clair dans ses interventions que ce
n'est pas la direction que notre
sociaux propos de madame petit pâté elle
se retrouvera pas dans le programme
libéral de sitôt il ya un parti en ce
moment au canada qui reçoit dans son
programme en fait parmi les trois
principaux partis c'est le npd justement
une formation politique qui essaie de se
distinguer des libéraux intéressant
merci louis je vous en prie